[Music]
how about another handsome
do-it-yourself pair the stock brothers
drew and Jonathan I know they're to your
favorites - yeah absolutely they have
got a new memoir out and it's called it
takes two it goes really deep into their
not so easy road to becoming the
property brothers that we all know and
love and our Brooke Anderson was with
them to talk about all of that but first
we had to ask how things are going with
Drew's latest dantian project I'm
excited I'm nervous on everything
Dancing with the Stars is something
we've both been asked to do over the
years but it's finally happening
Drew's going after that coveted
Mirrorball trophy with dance Pro Emma
Slater who's also a twin six weeks into
rehearsals they're calling themselves
team hot property does he have rhythm
his nicknames the robots we always joke
for like someone's gonna have to give
the robot some heart cuz on the dance
floor you need some heart listen you
know I'm a slim guy but I've lost 25
pounds in the last about six weeks I've
put on a quarter of those just to
support that's how he's gonna be plenty
busy the brothers are still in
production on their HGTV series along
with Drew's fiancee Linda Phan
we haven't started it yet for the
wedding you've been engaged since last
descent December so drew has set the
date he wants the renovation completed
but has not set the date of the wedding
this is there a priority priorities
priority my more it is life is good for
the 39 year old twins who combined net
worth is a reported 20 million dollars
but it wasn't always that way they get
candid about some dark times in their
new memoir it takes to our story we've
never really talked about our personal
lives very much you know I went through
a divorce and anyone who's been through
that knows how painful that can be
I mean I didn't even go on a date for
six months and you talk about
accumulating a pretty massive debt at
one point in your life yeah my passion
was acting and I never thought that it
wouldn't happen and I spent all my
savings I accumulated over a hundred
thousand a debt while the guys credit
their tight bond for getting through it
all there are some things the twins wish
they could swap I would take his middle
name silver is so much cooler than
Alfred the truth my initials are asked
actually drew those initials are a a I'm
not trying to drill alpha time there you
go all right I just want to get out of
this it's not possible
[Music]
you